Speaker 1: Sadly, another American journalist
has been killed by Russian troops this time.
Maybe journalist isn't the right word, a member
of the media, a cameraperson, and it is getting
very dangerous in Ukraine to be a member of
the media.
Media reporting Fox News cameraman killed
in attack that wounded Benjamin Hall Earlier
in the week, we talked about the injury to
Benjamin Hall.
We now are learning about the death of cameraman
Pierre Brewski, who was killed outside Kiev
in Ukraine.
Fox News Media CEO Suzanne Scott announced
the tragic news in a note to colleagues.
She said the crew ski, 55 years old, and Hall
were reporting in the village of Arancha when
their vehicle was struck by incoming fire.
Ukrainian officials say Aleksandra Khufu Schoonover,
the producer working with the Fox News team,
was also killed in the attack.
The notice says, dear colleagues, it is great
with great sadness and a heavy heart that
we share the news this morning regarding our
beloved cameraman, Pierre Zak Rusedski.
He was killed in a ranka outside of Kiev.
Ukraine was with Benjamin Hall yesterday news-gathering
when their vehicle was struck by incoming
fire.
The Hill also reporting on this Fox cameraman
killed amid attack in Ukraine.
This article mentions a little bit more about
the crew ski and the degree to which this
is crossing party lines.
And you know, I think there's a lot of people
may not realize in media.
Very often the camera, people, cameramen,
camera women around the world.
Sometimes they're freelance contractors.
I mean, they may technically be employees,
or they may be freelance contractors or whatever
the case may be.
But the point is they very often don't subscribe
to the same political views as the media outlet,
which they are covering.
And the understanding is, I mean, listen,
regardless.
This would be a tragedy, and attacks on UN
members of the media are deplorable and absolutely
sickening and disgusting.
But some people reacted by saying, Well, here's
here's a right winger who got killed.
Not that it would make it any less bad.
Very often these are sometimes their union
and internationally, sometimes they're freelance,
and that's just that's just neither here nor
there.
I think an important point to mention is that
in general, it's dangerous to be a journalist.
Journalists, not necessarily cameraperson
when Russia doesn't like what you're doing
and as dangerous as it as it has become on
a statistical basis in Ukraine so far, we've
now had multiple deaths in a number of members
of the media injured.
You can also look up the Wikipedia article
list of journalists killed in Russia, and
they actually have a table that goes by a
year and the numbers are quite high.
They're in the hundreds, in the hundreds for
journalists killed in Russia.
It is not good.
Here is CNN correspondent Scott McLean, CNN.
Remember sort of paying tribute to appear
as a crew.
Speaker 3: We should also point out that we
learned that a long time photojournalist peers
a crew ski for Fox News where his body was
found.
He's been killed in Kiev.
Yeah, that's right.
The second foreign journalist to be killed
was working for Fox News.
We understand the correspondent as well is
in critical condition, according to Fox.
I actually had opportunity to meet here two
years ago when I was in Kiev.
I can tell you he was extremely popular in
the industry.
It's pretty small and disagree, especially
on the road with international journalists.
Everybody seemed to know him.
I don't usually drink a lot when I'm on the
road because we're busy, but I can tell you
on our last night, I have a picture with him
and we were three sheets to the wind because
he was just a lovely guy to hang out with
and we were just having a riot hanging out
with the fox guys.
I ended up running into him in twenty twenty
a few months later when we were in the lockdown
in London, where he was living, and I just
remember he was really trying to get out the
door trying to.
He was bored sitting around in London during
the lockdown.
And so.
I know that he really loved his job, he really
loved the travel, he really loved the adventure.
Obviously, this is a tragedy and it seems
like he's universally loved in this industry.
And I can tell you from my brief experience
with him, he was just a really lovely guy
to be around.
Speaker 1: So there's the personal tragedy.
Someone died here.
Someone with a family has died.
There's also the reality that, yes, war journalism
is not without its dangers.
There's no question about it, but it's it's
a small sample.
This has been a short engagement so far this
invasion of Ukraine by Russia and and we,
you know, the number of people killed is thankfully
low in terms of the raw number.
But on a proportions basis for how many journalists
are there and how long it's been.
Russia is not taking particular care, not
taking particular care when it comes to members
of the media.
And it is getting dangerous enough in Kiev
that a 36 hour curfew has been announced after
residential buildings were hit by heavy shelling.
So all part of the tragedy, the invasion is
a tragedy.
The civilians killed a tragedy.
Members of the media killed its bad members.
You know, people, Ukrainian citizens just
defending their country.
It's all absolutely horrifying.
And by the way, I would say it's also a tragedy
when Russian soldiers are sent without a clue
sometimes as to what's really even going on.
And very often not even wanting or believing
that this is a worthy cause when they are
killed.
I mean, a lot of them are kids as well.
So it's all tragedy.
Let me know what you think you can find me
on Twitter at Packman.
We have a packed program for you today.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer, listener,
audience, community supported program, we
have a membership program which you can sign
up for at join Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
We also provide a commercial free audio and
video feed of every single show, every day
for our members, and it's made available six
hours before the shows are made public.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
Very easy to do.
Takes just moments.
And remember, Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
All the
Speaker 4: bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is
Speaker 1: bad.
Hard to imagine a better endorsement of the
bonus show than the fact that Alex Jones is
infuriated by it.